ukraine has suffered horrific attacks
missiles and airstrikes have torn
through apartment blocks
tanks have rolled into once peaceful
cities
innocent people including children have
lost their lives
the situation is fluid but as of today
putin has not taken any major cities
their advance has been slowed by
ukraine's fierce resistance
putin's invasion is not proceeding to
plan
he expected to take cities quickly
he expected ukraine to retreat and he
expected the west to be divided
instead his forces were met by the
heroic heroism of president zielenski
and the resolute determination of the
ukrainian people he has been met by a
united west together with our friends
around the world and we have taken
decisive action
today we have acted with the us the eu
japan and canada to cut russia's central
bank off from our markets
the ruble has fallen by over 40 as a
result
as much as 250 billion dollars have been
wiped off the russian stock market and
today their stock market is closed the
eu germany sweden and others are
following our lead in providing
defensive weapons to ukraine
germany has frozen nordstrom too
putin has been confounded by our
collective response
that is why here is resorting to more
and more extreme rhetoric
but of course the situation remains dire
the government and people of ukraine are
facing a continued onslaught
the days ahead are likely to prove
tougher still
the uk and our allies will have to
undergo some economic hardship
as a result of our sanctions
but our hardships are nothing compared
to those endured by the people of
ukraine
casualty numbers are rising and over 300
000 people have already been displaced
this is a struggle for ukraine's freedom
and self-determination
but it is also a struggle for freedom
and democracy everywhere
and for a survival of a europe whole and
free
we feel a particular responsibility as
the uk is a signatory to the 1994
budapest memorandum which prided ukraine
with security guarantees
this premeditated invasion
in violation of international law and
multiple international commitments
cannot succeed
putin must lose
we are doing everything we can to stop
him and to restore ukraine's sovereignty
and territorial integrity
we will do this by backing ukraine
against unjustified aggression by
degrading the russian economy and
stopping it funding putin's war machine
and by isolating putin on the world
stage
first of all we're backing ukraine with
defensive weapons humanitarian aid and
economic support
the uk was the first european nation to
send defensive weapons to the country
those weapons are being used today to
halt russian tanks and defend ukrainian
towns and cities
our latest consignment of defensive
support left brides norton over the
weekend
we're also leading on humanitarian
support
yesterday my right honourable friend the
prime minister announced a further 40
million of humanitarian aid this will
provide ukrainians with access to basic
necessities and vital medical supplies
we call on russia to enable humanitarian
access and safe passage for civilians to
flee the violence
the uk is also supporting ukraine's
economy including through 100 million of
odor and guarantees of up to 500 million
dollars in development bank loans
secondly we are cutting off funding for
putin's war machine
we're coming together with the us the g7
and the eu to take further decisive
steps we've been joined by australia
singapore switzerland and many more
there is a growing list of countries who
are determined that this aggression
cannot stand
we've agreed many russian banks will be
removed from the swift system
kicking them out of international
finance this is the first step towards a
total swift ban
our collective action against russia's
central bank will prevent them from
deploying their international reserves
to mitigate the impact of our sanctions
we're also launching a joint task force
to hunt down the assets of oligarchs hit
by our sanctions
the uk is proud to lead by example we've
already put in place the largest package
of sanctions in our history
we sanction putin and lavrov russia's
defense industry and a growing list of
oligarchs
we've approved asset freezes on several
russian banks we're banning russian
airlines and private jets from our
airspace but we are determined to go
much much further
we want a situation where they can't
access their funds their trade can't
flow their ships can't dock and their
planes can't land
today i can inform the house i will be
laying two new pieces of sanctions
legislation
the first introduces a set of new powers
against russia's financial sector
it includes powers to prevent russian
banks from clearing payments in sterling
with over 50 per cent of russian trade
denominated in dollars or sterling our
coordinated action with the united
states will damage russia's ability to
trade with the world
and as soon as this legislation comes
into force we will apply it to spare
bank russia's largest bank
i will also be imposing a full asset
freeze on free further banks
veb
russia's national development bank solve
com bank the third largest privately
owned financial institution in russia
an auth creator one of russia's largest
commercial banks
we will bring in a full asset freeze on
all russian banks in days
looking to coordinate with our allies
this same legislation will prevent the
russian state from raising debt here and
it will isolate all russian companies
that's over three million businesses
from accessing uk capital markets
global giants like gazprom will no
longer be able to issue debt or equity
in london
the second piece of legislation will ban
exports to russia across a range of
critical sectors
this includes high-end technological
equipment such as microelectronics
marine and navigation equipment
this will blunt russia's
military-industrial capabilities and act
as a drag on russia's economy for years
to come
i appreciate the consequences of this
step for british people and british
businesses operating in russia and the
department of international trade and
the treasury will offer advice and
guidance to affected uk businesses my
consular staff will continue to support
british nationals in russia as well as
those in ukraine
and we will keep ratcheting up our
response
more legislation will follow in coming
weeks in sanctioning russian-occupied
territories in the donbass extending
more sanctions to belarus and limiting
russian deposits in uk banks
we will continue working through our hit
list of oligarchs focusing on their
houses their yachts and every aspect of
their lives
in addition we will be introducing the
economic crime bill tomorrow my right
honourable friend the business secretary
will be setting out more in the next
statement in the house
this is all about flushing out the
oligarch's dirty money from the united
kingdom
and we will continue to work with our g7
allies to cut off the russian economy
and cut the free world's dependence on
russian gas depriving putin of his key
source of revenue
finally we're leading the diplomatic
effort to ensure there is a chorus of
condemnation against president putin
in the osce a key part of the european
security architecture
45 countries condemn russia by name
at the un security council on friday
over 80 un members voted for or
co-sponsored a resolution condemning
russia's aggression russia stood alone
in opposing it
putin is isolated
no one is willing to back his war of
choice
in recent days i've spoken to my
counterparts in more than 20 countries
around the world
yesterday i met g7 foreign ministers
where we were joined by ukraine's brave
foreign minister my friend dimitro
calaba
everyone is clear putin must lose and we
will carry on increasing the pressure
until he does
we have all seen ukraine's determination
to fight
putin's war could end up lasting for
months and years
so i say to our ukrainian friends
we're with you
in britain and around the world we're
prepared to suffer economic sacrifices
to support you
however long it takes we will not rest
until ukraine's sovereignty is restored
i commend this statement to the house